well as you might guess I have some bad
news Bret Stephens who is a resident of
New York City is unable to come due to
some bad weather reporting apparently
not actually bad weather but just bad
weather forecasting his flight was
canceled so he was unable to come Fred
Segal has graciously agreed to speak
this evening at 8pm and the good news is
that we have a treat here on stage with
us we felt so bad about mr. Hewitt
saying that we invited him in January
that we asked him to stay another day so
he could he could enjoy temperatures
above 20 degrees with the sun out today
this front row is really good he laughs
at my jokes he's going to interview dr.
aren't on the importance of a free press
I need no I need not introduce our dear
president dr. Arnn as you all know him
or if you don't we'll soon know him and
Hugh Hewitt I give them to you both
right now please join me me me and
welcoming them now I I'm glad to be back
in my more natural environment which is
asking questions this is what I like to
do now I do this weekly with President
aren't on the hillsdale dialogue and I
try and stump him each week and he's
from Arkansas and I'm from Ohio so
that's not very difficult and so I I
promised on his home turf I would be
easy on him but first I learned from
Kyle with whom I have more
correspondence than I do practically
anyone in my family because of these
weekly conversations with dr. Ron Coomer
not over here I asked him about the
biermann's center and for the benefit of
people watching at home who may not know
about this place and who it is named for
I thought it might be appropriate if you
told us that story because I was charmed
by Frank Biermann I was made to a
wonderful woman whose pictures over
there and
she was what we call a what do we call
him we call a non-traditional student
let's say she was in her late 40s maybe
when she came 30s when she came here and
she was on our track team she was a
tremendous runner and she died of an
illness long time ago and Frank grieves
for her still and Frank gave us most of
the money for this building and it's a
he's a really great man you should meet
him he comes around here a lot and the
building is tremendously useful it has
the best I think it's probably the best
in the country indoor track because it's
the first one built after new standards
came in so that you have to have relaxed
curves that makes for a bigger building
and faster indoor times without having
to train more attract people love that
and and it's designed so that like these
things when you these big murals when
you turn them over that those things are
permanent they state the meaning of the
college you should go read them we try
to remember that here and these murals
on this side they all turn over and
their sports themes on them so we
designed the building so we could cover
up athletics and and have commencement
in here it's a good place for that we
have some big screens that come down and
so now we have a nicer place to have
commencement in the third use of it
apart from athletics and commencement
and ceremonies like this is it's a big
indoor playground and you can see
there's a lot of light in here and so if
the winner is really bad and this is not
a bad winner Hugh is just a weenie if
it's really bad then the students turned
into vampires and they stay up all night
and they get kind of sallow and they
grow fangs and if you and there and they
get depressed and feel awful and the
pressure of everything overcomes them
and so the only solution we found is to
bring them in here and make them sweat
it's a wonderful building and when you
say non-traditional student she wasn't
like 25 she
was a decade or more over than and she
was on your cross country team yeah oh
yeah she was good too she's very good I
think that's terrific now second
question before i go to national
security and press freedom this one is
of course very relevant to that do you
think Secretary of State Clinton would
be a less bad president and President
Obama how could she not you know in
statistics they always say you have to
it's very deceptive if you have a bar
graph and you don't start it at zero
because that exaggerated the difference
and so I think President Clinton will be
significantly better than President
Obama and if you start the bar graph at
zero and he's here she'll be like there
yeah I think I think there's a lot of
dangerous things going on in the
government now and she might perpetuate
them but and dangerous things as to what
we turn in our nearly absolute free
press that we enjoy is that good for
freedom over the long haul or does
history show us that restrictions from a
wartime are in fact necessary even in
peacetime because peacetime is no longer
peacetime well I want to stay to general
premise to start and then I'll agree
with what I think is the trend of your
question the general thing I want to say
is that I think that there are
increasing controls on speech and that
they are advocated openly in the
government chicago law professor and
cass sunstein who is the regulatory czar
in the first Obama term and permitted
himself to be called that frankly
contends for such things Tom West here
and I have debated him about that in the
past and what they think is and the
mccain-feingold regulation law campaign
finance regulation had the explicit
purpose and it was a bipartisan bill
McCain and Phi
Gold John McCain and the liberal senator
now out of the Senate from Wisconsin its
purpose was to stop people from being so
critical of Congress within 90 days of
an election and so I think that's the
trend and I think all of the First
Amendment freedoms which are the central
freedoms because they have to do with
the specific human gift of reason and
speech from which arises conscience and
worship are more heavily constrained as
time goes on and increasingly so now
your question I think that there are
some constraints on speech and I think
that they're found in national security
and in libel harming the reputation of a
person in writing or slander harming the
repetition of a person in in speech and
those are old hallowed exceptions and
there are constraints on them and there
should be there must be so you know
there have been enormous breaches of
national security in recent years by
people who took an oath not to do that
and those are wrong but you have to have
and so their judgments that come up
because of that and you have to have a
political process that is constrained by
a constitution and by representation of
the people that puts a check on how much
of that there can be and there should be
the utter minimum necessary the bridge
have the Official Secrets Act in which
you are probably much more familiar than
I am I'm a signatory to it are you oh
yeah I used to work in the Churchill
archive and you had to sign it so tell
us about whether or not that's a good
thing for free people because earlier at
lunch day you were saying Churchill
explain why England is itself free and
so they have this much more draconian
much more draconian punishment of people
who are breakers of that oath that you
sign than we do our oath breakers end up
for fitting book royalties Frank's snap
of the zi8 cetera do you think they're
better served by an official secrets act
and
we are by not oh yeah there's is not too
bad and remember the context you don't
have to work for the government even in
America today and in Britain today there
are actually jobs that are not jobs
inside the government hard to believe
though it is and and so if you're going
to become privy to the government
secrets and it must have some because it
has enemies and you sign this act then
you have taken to voluntary step and you
don't have to take it if you don't want
to so that's part 1 part 2 is the libel
law that you referred Britain again
where you labored for a lot of us has a
much more draconian libel law it's much
easier to be pulled into the dock we
have the New York Times V Sullivan
standard we're practically is impossible
to libel you or me because we're public
public people and so the standard is it
was reckless disregard for the truth or
knowing falsity with malice aforethought
the Brits have a much lower standard
what do you make of the relative systems
well you're the lawyer here not i but as
i understand it what what that doctrine
or that what you named says is that if
it's a public figure that you say
something bad about you have to prove
malice against the person or knowing
falsehood it's not just that it mustn't
it has to be true because if you say
something bad about me or I about you
and it isn't true and it causes you harm
then that's a legal tort you're not
supposed to do that to people and
recovery is possible just like if you
burn somebody's house down Madison I
actually prepared a little for this in a
shocking development and Madison I found
him today writing that a danger to harm
to your reputation is a more serious
kind of harm than taking somebody's
property the property can be restored so
the English law doesn't have that
exception in that exception ought not to
be in my opinion because if you harm
somebody you should they should be able
to recover against you and
I found a place where Ben Franklin by
the way you should all read this if you
go to if you do it google for founders
Constitution that's it online at the
University of Chicago presses website
addition of a really great book by
kurland and learner that takes all the
provisions of the Constitution and you
click on one of them it was originally
six big fat books and it shows you
usually 25 to 35 writings about the
meaning of the I've never heard of this
in my life oh wow it's a it's it's it's
it might be about the meaning of the
causes of the Constitution the best
single thing there is about the MTG
coasters law for 15 years I've never
heard just got you by the way you will
love it I will love it and i can tell
you i have them on my ipad they're 35
231 i think about the the First
Amendment about the speech Clause of the
First Amendment just that part and Ben
Franklin said that that you should have
if we were weakening the libel laws we
would have to strengthen the law of the
cudgel and what that means is somebody
says something really bad about you it's
not sure you should knock him down it's
what Pope Francis said last week about
anyone who made an insult about his
mother yeah when and wasn't that a shame
his attitude about a less but if you you
need and see once you have once you
liberalize the lot the libel laws you
know by the way there have been things
said about me the first rule of public
right occurs don't repeat the charges
against you but there was a radio
program in public radio somewhere in the
United States about two years ago about
me and the list of things they said
about me are astonishing and bear no
relation to my opinions and the fact
that they studied about my life are
entirely wrong and they didn't bother
ever to call me I still to this day have
not heard from them nor replied because
why would i but you see that you know I
could
so I live every day with this and I I
know that the trade-off is while people
can say one public radio station
compared to like every single day and
other people do deal with this every day
the ability to speak into the public
sector without fear of someone suing me
and causing me any kind of art marc
Stein has lived the other side of this
where this crazy lawsuit has been filed
against him for his opinion on global
warming it has dogged him for three or
four years it ought to have been
dismissed immediately so I have a great
affection for this but I'm curious that
you're suggesting the framers did not
intend it to go and here's another thing
see because things are very distorted
now it's very hard to recover it I
believe by the way it is the single most
useful exercise to recover the system of
government we used to have and in the
system of government we used to have
lawsuits work differently and by the way
they still work substantially that way
in England because in England you didn't
have the right of discovery you know you
had to know the facts or find them out
somehow on your own you couldn't put
somebody you sued to the expense of
defending lawsuit if it was frivolous
and then a second thing in England it's
still possible to recover attorneys fees
and so the way that you know and so Hugh
is in a terrible conflict because he's a
public figure and a journalist and makes
part of his living from that and he's a
lawyer and makes part of his living from
that and those two changes are enormous
full employment for lawyer provisions
that are recent innovations in America
alone not in the rest of the
english-speaking world so if you lived
in a world where if you want to sue
somebody for libel first of all you'd
have what he said and you could prove
that it wasn't true or you couldn't and
second of all the one who loses the
lawsuit pays the legal fees and that
isn't into
Xmen against frivolous lawsuits but I I
go back to the idea that if you weaken
that people will be less wholesome in
their criticism of public officials at
this moment we don't want a week in that
at all the Fairness Doctrine I was
talking about last night public
officials protected for a long time
mccain-feingold was an attempt to
protect public officials from criticism
within 60 days of their election that
was struck down as unconstitutional I am
I'm sad that people are not more
responsible because they're not better
but I'm also happy that I don't have to
worry about frivolous lawsuits well
there's there's some historical answer
to that too because it is probably true
and there was a lawsuit about it that is
one of the key pieces of evidence we
have about this the Thomas Jefferson
hired a scandalous journalist by the
name of James Callender well Thomas
Jefferson was Secretary of State and
it's not unlikely that he paid him with
funds from the secretary from the
Department of State to write dirty
articles in the Philadelphia newspaper
about Alexander Hamilton and there was i
mean the the you know alexander hamilton
was probably illegitimate and we know
that in part from james calendar and the
Sally Hemings story about Thomas
Jefferson comes from stories in the
press when he was alive and important in
America so those laws didn't stop one
from you know and remember one of the
things you have to believe if you're a
scholar and if you believe in the truth
and if you try to teach young people to
seek it though it's hard to find
especially about big things you have to
believe that the facts are what they are
and that if you've got an expeditious
way to find out what they are then
justice is likely to be done and then
you would get you know because this line
between saying dirty stuff about people
in politics and letting them run free
and destroy marks teens five years of
peace of mind and because you said
expeditious which is yeah what are you
can see see
the problem with that lawsuit against
mark steyn who's a tremendous man you
know and a some kind of a genius is what
that guy is the problem with that is not
that it's been filed the problem with it
is it's so expensive to get to the end
of it yes and so they and somebody rich
or some collection of rich interest
files a lawsuit against you and then
your punishment begins the minute it's
filed and it's not over to you're broke
that's what's wrong and your night's
sleep or God's I've never ever
recommended to a client that they sue
anyone for live on the matter how grieve
is the library now can't win now I want
to talk to you about your framers and
their attitude towards treasonous speech
the Alien and Sedition Act is a feature
of the early republic what are your
thoughts we'll explain to people what
the Alien and Sedition Act is and
whether it's consistent with what you
thought the framers thought they were
doing in Philadelphia what's the framers
key about I think I didn't choose the
title it's a good title and people ought
to read the framers pretty good so first
of all one of the fundamental fights in
the early american republic after the
constitution was over this 1798 law
signed by John Adams that said that if
you say certain things critical of the
government or provoking sedition then
you could be fined and imprisoned and
that was a that was a sort of an
implementation of the British law of
seditious libel and so libel is saying a
bad thing about a private individual
that is it true and seditious libel is
saying a bad thing about the government
and the English had the most liberal
system in the world at the time and what
it what it established was two things
that were
under full developments on the laws that
existed in most of the world before and
one was there couldn't be a prior
restraint that is to say you couldn't
you couldn't made there's a 16 I'm found
it today there's a 1668 law in England
that said that you couldn't publish
anything about the government until
you'd submitted to the registry and had
it approved censorship in advance and so
no prior restraint you could publish
what you want and then second if you're
hauled up truth is the legitimate
defense and so the Alien and Sedition
Acts kind of follows that line and the
and you know first of all Alexander
Hamilton in the in the Federalist Party
a colleague of John Adams opposed this
thing John Marshall the great federalist
judge allowed later that he had wasn't
in the Congress when it was passed but
that he would have opposed it and if it
came up again he would oppose it again
but Thomas Jefferson and James Madison
who were busy founding what became the
Democratic Party was a very different
thing back in those days you know it's
the party's changed so much although
they have long continuity in America and
the change in the Democratic Party is as
radical as the change in the Republican
Party which used to be really
intelligent that's an easy joke and
there are as a lot of intelligence in
both political parties today somewhat
different principles so they took order
after that thing really hard and the
Virginia legislature published something
written by James Virginia resolutions
and the Kentucky legislature publish
something pick it up again
they could swallow it in your tie yep
it's is dead thank you all for coming
yeah what you could scare it to put me
up no it's not I shouldn't have to do
that but you're a taller mute person I'm
exactly they're back I am exactly the
height of Winston Churchill so they took
off after that thing and they and the
Kentucky and the Virginia resolutions
and they're different in important ways
because unconstitutional subjects James
Madison in my reading is much smarter
than Thomas Jefferson but they both call
for the states to interpose to stop this
invasion of the fundamental freedoms of
the country and madison who's virginia
resolutions are very worth reading and
they're in curling and learner and
they're anywhere on the internet and in
our Constitution reader they make the
case that that the English law is not
good enough and that you should write
what you want about the government and
within the law but the constraints the
law of libel you can write it and you
can criticize people in office and you
can say they're disreputable and there's
you know by the way there's all kinds of
things you can say about a person that
are hard to prove that they're not true
and those things by the way tend to be
discounted by the hearer and that means
that under a law where the libel laws
ran you could calumny eight people all
you wanted to if you just did it
carefully but it's when you get specific
and you say they this bad thing and that
bad thing that and those are the things
that carry more conviction so there was
a split over the Alien and Sedition Acts
they were passed only to run for to
congress's that it's a 44 44 years and
they expired and one part of them I'm
told did not expire it is still on the
books and I wish I could remember what
part that is but I don't so let me
follow up so you were along with the
framers is it working now no new
handheld okay I take it from your
remarks that you agree with Jefferson in
opposition of the Alien and Sedition Act
Madison Madison and as a result it's
okay to libel the government it's okay
to injure the government no be a speech
the law you know first of all disclosing
secrets harmful you anticipate where I'm
going yeah that that is not legal was
not legal in that system but they're not
secret after this is the nub of it
Snowden is a traitorous treasonous
criminal Snowden gives his secret
material to someone who's not signed the
oath the New York Times New York Times
publishes the traitor is treason in this
material they're not publishing a secret
about which they have been obliged that
they've signed it out so ought they to
be punished the New York Times for
publishing it under the law that can be
and that I even favor that law but one
of the reasons I favor it is because
it's very hard to do and it always has
been and Snowden it looks to me like
he's in an unambiguous situation yes and
and the people who then republish it or
in the ambiguous or in an ambiguous
situation and my opinion is they ought
not to do that and and you know the way
that has worked in some classic
instances in American history is that
you know I I'm Abraham Lincoln and
somebody's got some information that
would harm
don't use that one that's a civil war
I'm Franklin Roosevelt and somebody's
got some information and I really lacked
the power in advance from stopping them
from doing anything and so there have
been in the past conversations where
somebody powerful government sat down
with somebody powerful in a in a media
outlet and they had a grown-up
conversation they encourage the person
in the media outlet to make a mature
judgment about it and many times they
have that many times they have it many
times they haven't and and you know the
once it gets there by the way that's a
problem right because because the
government is going to a person who has
the right of freedom of speech and
suppressing them and in my opinion there
are conditions where they could rightly
do that but you don't like that and you
don't want it to happen often and so
often it's just better to suffer the
harm in general and I can show you where
James Madison rights that what I was
that the curator tell us about what he
thought we do yourself an arm what he
thought was that Jefferson too thought
this they wrote exactly the same about
this they thought that you know in the
end they believe this they believe that
the granting and protection of freedom
by a government is its greatest source
of respect and so claims against it are
a sign of that freedom and they
reinforce it at the same time as they
criticize it and that a government that
says that you can't do that is one that
leads to rebellion and so they thought
that it was better almost always to let
people say what they want there are two
specific instances in the last 12 years
Snowden is one the other is a
publication by the New York Times of the
money
following technology of America that the
managing editor of The Washington bureau
of the Los Angeles Times admit to me on
air probably have the effect of alerting
terrorists that we were close to getting
probably allowed terrorists to escape to
continue their rampage and kill people
so we have Snowden who did us billions
of dollars worth of them hundreds of
billions of dollars of damage and we
have the new the Los Angeles Times
facilitating the escape of terrorists in
either of those cases would you have
counseled the government to prosecute
them well I'd have to know the facts as
i said before Snowden should be
prosecuted I'm tied up in the papers the
answer is I'd be very reluctant to do
that and an ni might but the other thing
about it is by the way it's so easy to
publish now and I I judge these things
partly you know in my maturity
differently than I might have 30 years
ago because what I think is going on is
I mean last night I sent in the final
edits to my book on Winston Churchill so
opinion I were drinking champagne it's
not because the book is good it's
because it's done and and I discovered
something yesterday and put it together
I'd read it before but it came to me
yesterday and I added something
Churchill understood that we are getting
the power through science to re-engineer
the actual physical human being to make
them in factories to limit their
capacity if you read brave new world
which was published in the 20s and for
all I know Churchill read it but in an
essay called 50 years hints he said
that's becoming a possibility and what
if we become manufactured objects how
will we be viewed by a powerful
government and other powerful sources in
the society and so I judge that the
comprehensiveness of government today is
a problem and so I'm looking for ways
and and by the way you don't have to
look far because ours is the best
government in human history to do the
two things we're talking about which is
to delegate and assemble power because
you need a lot of it in this world
especially and more as time goes on and
to limit the use of that power and so
things that that that that touch on the
place where those two needs come
together that's where the Constitution
operates and I'm inclined to judge in
favor of restraint wherever possible can
the President as he did with allah ki
sent a drone to kill an American on
foreign soil is beyond the capture of
the law but he poses an immediate threat
do you dispute his power to do that by
the way no neither do i I think it's
perfectly appropriate for him to John
that i've argued that could the
president do the same thing if we can
stop allah ki from injuring Americans
why can't they stop journalists from
publishing that which will injure
Americans well the answer to that is
obvious and I'm saying that there are
some cases I imagine where they could
but the answer is obvious the purpose of
the government and therefore the purpose
of the war is to protect the right
that's being interfered with so I can
show you in the second world war for
example where in in both world wars
where Winston Churchill talks about
things that they're doing in the war
that that have to stop the second the
war is over and I can show you fighting
I can down so i'll name two more things
i can show you the second the war is
over him making motions to get those
things stopped in the third in 1936
Winston Churchill wrote a essay called
what good's a constitution and it
published it in 35 in Britain and in 36
in the United States and that's during
the court packing fight right because
the Supreme Court the United States
struck down the New Deal and Churchill
takes the side of the
and he says this argument that an
economic crisis could be a parallel to a
war and remember we just passed the 50th
anniversary of the war on poverty and
poverty in those regions and everywhere
that that war has been waged is the same
or worse than it was and we spent enough
money on it to make everybody in a
condition of poverty rich through
endowment that is to say set aside a
bunch manages pay it from to him every
year and Churchill says that if you if
you build the conditions of war is an
ongoing thing the danger is you'll
destroy the liberal nature of the
society for we all need room to move and
leave live our own lives and so he was
very against that kind of thing and this
war on terror which goes on on on and
may go on by the way in perpetuity until
it eats us because I don't see how we're
going to beat it that means that we need
principles of constraint that will
protect the liberal nature of the
society and we need to be working on
those hard to the issue of surveillance
of our citizenry who might be involved
in subversive activities we've been
around this block a few times in the 50s
and in the 20s what do you think of the
current balance is struck Snowden if
nothing else had lumen than the extent
of the apparatus we have the guarantee
and I trust it that we are not being at
you and I are being observed because Ron
circuit television to the world anyone
who wants to so we have no expectation
of privacy what do you think about the
expectation of privacy in the national
security state well I think the
principles are easy to understand first
of all information about you belongs to
you unless you give it away and there's
a lot of in the internet right like I
signed up for something with verizon and
the other day
and and I did it on the phone and three
minutes later I went on the Internet to
open my account and it asked me a series
of questions which addresses if i lived
at in the last 20 years wherever I've
been employed in the last 20 years I
didn't give many that you know how they
know the answer is everything is known
right yes let me just make a public
statement that I didn't do it and and so
so I worry about that stuff I think that
laws could be written like the FBI is
protesting against the encryption of
data on phones and i'm in favor of that
i think the FBI is wrong so the first
thing is information about you is yours
unless you give it away those rules
don't apply more time do they did they
apply in great britain during wartime
did Churchill's available British
citizens yeah he did and he didn't like
it and what he did it and he talked
about the constraints on it and remember
Churchill and Churchill believed in this
very much Churchill had to go and make a
case in front of a parliament that had
the power to remove him any day and ask
all kinds of awkward questions about it
and it's now known that well first of
all he would sometimes say I can't talk
about this and so every once in a while
they had a secret session and those
things are all available now you can go
read the secret session debates of the
House of Commons during the Second World
War and very often he describes in there
in detail what's going on and what the
restraints on it are so now when you get
into government so you and I know some
people in Congress and some over lawyers
and we tend to have confidence in the
same ones and I can tell you that I
press them on this a lot and they tell
me that there are in fact checks and
balances on this snooping in the form of
independent judges the foreign
intelligence surveillance court to which
i clerked when you yeah that's what I
was referring to earlier and it looks to
me like
you need that thing and I hope it's
strong and people who know a lot about
it tell me that it is and I'm asking you
now is it yesterday it was in I thought
it was in the Reagan administration
first term when I was the assistant to
the Attorney General for that court
however two of the people that we have
it friends in common on the radio and
you in person are Senator Tom cotton and
Congressman Mike Pompeo they are both
members of the House and the Senate
Intelligence Committee respectively I've
talked with them on the air about this
this is nothing they won't tell you
anything that goes on there but they are
the oversight branch their members of
the oversight branch are close to both
of them do you think the government
tells them everything because that's the
key question I think it should and
whether it does or not I can't tell you
because they've set it on the radio they
don't express big anxiety about that to
me they think they can find out what
they need to know and and I hope so
because remember the structure see and
if we in you know here's what I think I
think that James Madison was correct
named the assertion and I can't think of
one right now where I wouldn't say he
was correct but but what he said was men
are not angels and angels do not govern
men and so you have to have these
controls and he states what they are
I'll tell you what they are it's easy to
list them the first check is that the
people of the United States elect their
government except vary by the way very
large part of it of course is not
elected anymore in hard to control its
most of it second the people themselves
you know who are also people and their
knows what they might do they don't do
anything they just work through
representatives so all of us have to
wait till election time right that's a
check on us third we delegate our
authority to different branches and
different levels of government and
Madison says that this
and forth their independent courts that
are not accountable in the immediate
sense to anything except honesty and
impeachable offenses so those four
things make a structure and James
Madison said that is the nature of the
thing that is the importance of the
Constitution to understand that
structure it's more important than the
Bill of Rights it's more important than
any provision in it and so I do not want
to waive that structure there are two
critiques out there on one end Glenn
Greenwald a radical journalist of
apparently no limits and what he will
reveal about the government Senator Rand
Paul friend of the Republican and and
doing great work and they range from
overt accusations of sinister action to
the implication of at least negligent
sinister action between grand lingual
and Rand Paul do you believe them to
have merit and if so how do you correct
it with in Madison structure well you
know again that's like this thing about
the law of libel and the way lawsuits
work today I'm in favor of big changes
and I don't expect to wake up in the
morning and have them made but you know
understand them and explain them that's
what's possible to do right now so it's
good idea to be working in a place
that's a learning institution one of the
reasons so what you need is you need you
know first of all look at the structure
you know the worst abuse is that i know
of have to do with the Internal Revenue
Service right and that's recent but also
in the Nixon administration and you just
don't want the government being able to
do that to you right and that's not good
and and you've if you look at article 1
section 8 of the Constitution of the
United States it it delegates the
authorities to Congress and about half
of them have to do with national
security and forever and ever and ever
for
50 years that was much the most of the
government the United States and now
it's what is it twenty percent something
like that 30 maybe I don't think it's 30
and and so you've just got a lot going
on on a massive scale that has to do
with the regulation of us and it's a
force unto itself and and and let me
mention when Tocqueville comes to the
United States in 1830s he notices how
much government there is more more than
in France right huge amount but its
character is local and voluntary I'm for
a lot of government at the central level
I'm for a supreme government that deals
with things that are listed in article 1
section 8 with the weight of what it
does and and then I think you know the
the government of Hillsdale Michigan
ought to have a lot more scope and
authority over our local lives than it
does and it used to have in you know
there are people alive today who saw
that and so I'm for that kind of reform
and and when you argue about
constitutionalism today it's very
important to sort of make a big picture
of how the whole thing operated of how
it operates now and the reasons behind
the change and then you can think about
reform my my approach with my law
students and i'll see if you think this
is all wet and if it is all abandoned
when the government was 100 total one
malignant one percent malignancy rate
was one bad actor one Aaron Burr when
the government is a million strong one
percent error rate is 10,000 malignant
actors can spread out across a variety
of agencies doing Lois Lerner like
things from a variety of places our
problem is not the structure a problem
is the good and or how we hire into that
I think that's our problem that's what
Rand Paul wants to overcorrect I think
sometimes he doesn't recognize
ninety-nine percent of the people who
work in
government are patriots sure and then
that one percent though has grown so
large by virtue of the expansion of the
government the only way actually to
solve that problem is to shrink the
government and to remove tenure and you
know angleton spent his life going crazy
trying to find moles to church a World
War II much about his moles he came in
after Philby was exposed or before film
us yeah and that was going on then but
remember those moles so Churchill
worried very much about communism right
Churchill you may be surprised learned
was an anti-communist and and he was
eloquent and persistent anti-communist
he said that the bolshevik society which
he said is a extreme form of things that
are present in our societies he said
that it it it it has no principle that
has not been conceived implemented for
millennia in the Society of the white
and it's one of several places where
Churchill said that under principles
that are prevailing in the modern world
we come to look like insects so I'm just
establishing his credentials and and in
1939 the Soviet Union made an alliance
with Nazi Germany and and that broke up
in 1941 when Hitler invaded his ally
Hitler you may be surprised learned was
not always honest in his dealings and
and so on that day The Daily Worker in
Britain and the communist movement in
Britain immediately reversed its tune
and became pro war and so whatever blunt
and Phil being McLean might have been
doing in nineteen thirty nine to
nineteen forty one they stopped doing it
in 1941 and then they were busy again
after the Fulton speech when Churchill
sort of declared acknowledged the
existence of the Cold War now I'm going
to go to questions in the audience on
this because I'm sure we have some in
the rand paul
and some who are not in the rand paul
world of suspicion but i have one quick
question before we do and i have to
leave at five and then you can get into
asking questions today is the 70th
anniversary of the liberation of
auschwitz by the communists 70 years ago
today what was Churchill's reaction to
the exposé of the camps well let that
that particular thing was not the expose
the news had been coming you may
surprise you know Churchill was also an
anti-nazi and he he he knew what they
were from 1933 but when the world came
to see that they had built factories to
kill people and process them it's also
true you know also I used to work for
sir martin gilbert and he's a great man
and one of the things he did has done is
write a bunch of books on the holocaust
and there are lots of memos massive
evidence of arguments between the
Gestapo and the ver moch the German
military about priority of transport
because the Gestapo wanted to sip Jews
and they and the military wonder ship
ammunition and soldiers and food and
supplies and the Gestapo often won those
arguments right it was a high priority
and it began to be understood when those
can't I mean what pub popularly
understood you know three guys escaped
from Auschwitz and they ended up in in
Israel interviewed if memory serves by a
man named Moshe sure talk I can show you
in Martin Gilbert's books where these
are and they describe this death camp
and he interviewed them for weeks
because he couldn't believe it you know
who could who could ok and there's a man
named Heintzman who's one of the
founders of modern Israel and he was a
chemist and in the First World War he
helped it played the largest part in
inventing an alternative to coordinate
which made explosive shells go up and
the Allies are running out of it and
when Churchill in the at the end of the
First World War was ministering
and he invites Minh became big buddies
and that Vice Minh comes into
Churchill's office after these report
comes to him now after they believed it
from Jerusalem about this camp and
vitamin could come see Winston Churchill
when he wanted to and he gives him a
list and the list is published in one of
Martin Gilbert's books and one of the
items on the list is I think it might
have been first but don't I'd have to go
look and be sure Martin Gilbert always
said one of his advices I give it to all
the students here is you have an
excellent memory and I have an excellent
memory and we do not rely upon our
memories with them yours everywhere look
it up but I think it might have been
first in the list to parachute somebody
and look at this thing and see if this
thing can be true and you know that this
is the Churchill who had written in the
30s that where things are going is that
we may become manufactured items with
all the dignity and respect pertaining
thereto and now it's there and he knew
that in in in Hitler early you should
read his speeches in the 30s their
tremendous explaining what this thing
means and remember Churchill's argument
all his life was that these extreme
ideologies are only extreme forms of
doctrines that are present among us and
when Eisenhower liberated the furthest
west camp his troops brought up and he
toured it and he came back and he
marched the German mayor and his wife
through the town they repaired to their
homes and they hung themselves
Eisenhower was shot shot so that
obviously that the Allied armies did not
have detailed knowledge of these pails
so did did Churchill record any reaction
i sourced yeah what was it well you have
to remember by the way that
the knowledge came out over time but
Churchill understood the point in
principle from the long Tyler early and
so the horror of the thing because you
know once its present in front of you
it's different and he spoke about that
I'd love to read that today now we have
10 minutes before I have to turn into a
pumpkin you can keep asking we have
first here in that up front Thank You
mr. Hewitt and dr. Arnn I would led to a
contest your point last night about no
one here under 50 having seen William
Buckley's firing line after attending a
coke internship program last summer our
speech code suggested that there was no
one better to learn speech from the mr.
Buckley I have seen experts of three
episodes of mr. Buckley's firing firing
line mr. Hewitt your interview style
reminds me mr. Buckley slightly you know
dr. are I suppose you most remind me of
your style of answering questions a bit
of Ron Paul 1970s mr. Hewitt I would
like to disagree that started as a
traitor because he's appealing to a
higher law than government which is
natural law but Americans be as rightly
our alarms as they are right now about
privacy rights if mr. Snowden had not
spoken his conscience it is an excellent
question it's the question I'm going to
defer to your president to answer that
question because my question is on the
radio I answer that over and over again
perhaps too abruptly but he's your
student is he I don't know are you he
said go debate coach so he gave up at
poker tell so so so every human being
has the right of revolution but the
people who first propelled that right
the philosophers and the Statesman also
understood that has to be used with
great caution and the reason it has to
be is because we must live under law we
are made for it is written in our nature
and I'm one of my favorite I'm one of my
favorite things to say because it's kind
of a joke is
the form of government least workable is
anarchy and so to take the step of
rebelling against your country is a very
big step that's why the Declaration of
Independence is written in the way that
it is and I haven't heard anything from
mr. Snowden a patch is eloquent is that
and I think we would be concerned about
privacy rights without him so I'm not
yet ready to style him Thomas Jefferson
my answer is much more blunt of course
he's a traitor or the word traitor does
not have any meaning so if you can come
up with a definition of traitor into
which he does not fit I'll entertain the
conversation but if our framers had
acted like Snowden they would have
signed the Declaration of Independence
and repaired immediately to continental
France which I might add what Jefferson
do so by the way remember Thomas
Jefferson was a traitor and at the
moment he wrote and the other side the
network's independence there was a rib
out for their arrest to an army and and
you just have to see the terms of the
declaration of dependence too because
it's the most brilliant beautiful
revolutionary document ever written in
my opinion and its case is this the King
has manifested and is practically
implementing the principle that he can
rule us however he pleases and without
our consent and so I don't believe that
that case is makeable today against the
American government and I pray that it
doesn't come to be and I'm afraid about
that kind of thing so I wouldn't make
that judgment the way he did but also I
don't think that the people who proclaim
him a hero they don't quite understand
how bad that thing is to do if you do it
because that's hell you know the
American Revolution was not an
the experience and it went about as well
as one can go there are there are
Americans dead because of Stoughton the
Crimea is probably taken because of
Snowden back into the darkness Snowden
if there is a eternal court sitting is
going to have a very long trial and
won't like the consequence but well put
yeah thank you both very much for doing
this mr. Hewitt last week you had an
interview with Senator Tom cotton of the
Senate Intelligence Committee and
obviously he has information that's very
sensitive now as a journalist you're
pursuing the truth obviously he has this
kind of information that if it were to
come out would be harmful to our country
so as a journalist when you're pursuing
the truth in that kind of interview how
do you prepare to ask these kinds of
questions without also well making him
release information or seeming like he's
withholding information done that's a
great question and I do it normally by
letting the audience know beforehand
that I understand my guests to be bound
by the O's that dr. Arnn referred to I
still have some of them in place from
1984 which I took regarding information
I saw which probably wouldn't interest
even a historian anymore but I remember
the oath and I remember what I can't
talk about so I always say I'm aware and
of course you're not going to answer
anything that would constraint but to
the extent of your ability will you tell
us and it has typically been the case
with Congressman pompeo and Senator
cotton that they will always say and i
don't think i can say any more than that
because they have a they have training
they have staff they have intelligence
professionals that advise them but one
of the most difficult things i'll close
here i'll leave you to tell this story
because i thought so fascinating at
lunch what you say can give away
bookshelves one line can give away
bookshelves and if you haven't seen the
imitation game the end of it is what do
you do with intelligence and i think dr.
aaron has to write in a chapter his book
about how churchill handled intelligence
but tell them about a dent mum and the
invasion as i leave you to go to the
515 because I think that we'll talk
about the difficulty of the subject that
we're dealing with here thank you very
much friends I have to go do radio yeah
so yeah so I'll tell you do you want to
know about enigma well the Germans you
know which were depressions are older
and the German states were older but it
came to be a country in 18 where's more
1866 thank you Richard reap its going to
get to ask a question before we go they
were very formidable in war and they
were also very German and war that is
they were very systematic and then the
second world war they had a machine an
encoding machine and they distributed it
around and they took German care and
preventing it from being seized and then
they changed the codes all the time and
they were very complex and it was very
hard to decode the codes and then you
had to put them into this machine after
you got that part right and the Allies
got their hands on a machine one of the
machines and then a lot of very
brilliant people figured out how to use
it and then they had to break the codes
all this took a long time and it
happened in bletchley park outside
london and that little place a little
little village the next thing you know
there's 20,000 people working out there
and nobody knew what they were doing and
they were going down the village road
and they kept the secret very well and
the man in charge of it was only
referred to in correspondence as C and
the number of people who knew what it
was outside Bletchley Park and the
people in Bletchley Park largely didn't
know what they were doing that is to say
the picked the whole picture about the
machine and all and the number of people
the in the British government who knew
was not as numerous as the cabinet and
Churchill himself read the decrypt every
day and they knew in detail and say
anytime from 19 middle of 1943 on they
knew in detail most of what Germany was
up to in the war and they ran him out of
South Africa faster because of that and
they much of their success and the
rapidity with which had happened had to
do with this thing and they were very
careful about how they use we have time
for one more question
my mind works I think on the liable
question which I almost hesitate to
return to after all that interesting
discussion but I think Alexander
Hamilton had the last word on that as
the lawyer in the appeal of people
versus croswell in New York 1802 and 18
and three he framed the principle of
libel law which prevailed until near
Times versus Sullivan which is to say
the truth is a defense as long as it's
done for good ends and without malice
okay and so I think that that whole era
era of libel law should be at least
recalled because the price we paid for
New York Times versus Sullivan has been
the assassination of a lot of public
careers reputations do you agree with it
I suppose you agree
I just heard it so I don't know what I
did to Ted but i'm easy going to undo it
or do more i don't know which but damn
um yeah so that that's right and and see
we the situation is distorted imagine a
society in which people are treated
before the law equally and is
responsible for their actions that's
what you want so somebody causes harm
there's a way to recover and that way to
recover it doesn't encourage spurious
attempts to to to shut people up because
you have to pay the legal bills for both
if you do that and trials are
expeditious and you go with the facts
that are available to you don't get to
fish around in somebody's stuff and so
in that world you've got you've got it
locates responsibility in general by the
way the thing about life in general to
think about management the thing about
education about teaching the thing about
government is you want to locate
responsibility and authority together
and that way people can all act and and
they will be improved by living in
existence where those two things are
together so you know I think party X is
a dirty dog well you know I might be
hesitant to call him that because as a
matter of fact I don't really know
whether he's dirty and he surely is not
a dog but I'll take the trouble to think
of what I really think and something I
can defend and this way of doing it is
it's everybody's a target and then the
next thing you know we're passing
comprehensive laws to regulate who can
say what in politics is an alternative
to that old system of justice which was
developed for a long time and I daresay
perfected in our country
thank you